why did we choose this life why did we
become superheroes we dedicate our lives
to fighting crime for one reason to make
a billion dollars on a superhero
franchise superheroes and video games
there's a lot of stuff to take the piss
out of ya there just is
we learned so much from stick of truth
that we decided let's do another one and
take everything we've learned and kind
of make it better and so we did learn a
lot and I think this game's gonna be
much much better and now it's gonna be
worse yeah I just I just said that so
there stick of truth and this literally
happens like the next day in town
everybody switch games with a superhero
and you're still that same character
you're still that kid that did all that
stuff with the stick dork like wearing a
little crown and now something new is
happening in town and so even though
you've really risen to prominence in the
stick of truth game they're all like
well you can't play this with us here
nobody again just seems like a perfect
RPG thing of like do this big powerful
person and now you're nothing and you
gotta work your way back Matt and Trey
are both gamers they've really invested
a lot of time and effort into this
project and working closely with Jason
and his team to make sure that they nail
this process perfectly even as we're
first starting to figure out the first
ideas of what it could be we brought
everyone from Ubisoft down and had them
in those meetings we have this big fight
where the kids split up and that's
basically backstory how come I have to
have the Netflix series I want a movie
to do I get my own movie not everyone
gets their own movie maybe we'll just go
and do our own franchise yeah yeah oh
you want silver warriors how would you
watch yeah dude Civil War you you get
out I'll be so cool for them to have be
in a fight on opposite sides
ma'am can he hit me right in the face
our goal what we said from the beginning
was we still want that feeling that
everyone had of you know putting their
underwear on the outside of their pants
and running around with a cape and being
like I'm gonna say bit down there's
nothing wrong with doing the exact same
movie to start a franchise go home read
on it I started going back and watching
PewDiePie plays take a truth this game
is really detailed you gotta appreciate
it for that man and it was just the best
material I could have because it was
like I was watching an audience member
play it and what they were thinking
about it they're all kind of similar
they attacks or whatever and going wow
this parks lame and I'm like okay that
part's lame you know I'm like you know
is this great to have that as a resource
who that ordinary citizen into the queue
they're they're RPG elements you can
level up your character there are
certain powers you can equip to your
character you have a team of buddies
that join you in all of your combat and
they all have their unique personalities
and powers as well it is an outrageous
tactical RPG in a superhero suit this
time it's serious game development is
different from the way that Matt and
Trey run the show we are very familiar
with their process over there they do a
six-day sort of turnaround from nothing
to making an actual episode for the show
and we do have to elongate that a little
bit for our game development process one
of the challenges that we knew we'd face
is that Trey wants to try stuff and
change stuff and we need to be as fast
as the show or at least try to get
somewhere close so the process begins it
comes out of the writers room when we
start with a script Trey will give us a
draft and the majority of the artwork
and design work that's going into this
game is designed by our department part
of the fun of the first game was that
you get to pick what type of character
you are what costumes you get to wear
part of this game is gonna have that -
or you get to sort of dress your
character up based on your superpower or
based on what type of superhero that you
are so these are some concepts that we
created to kind of
what these kids would look like there's
a very specific style to South Park not
everyone can just simply animate and
make it look like South Park does a lot
of little nuances that I've had to learn
it is much more complex than some of
them more high graphic games that I've
worked on simply because it's so
hand-drawn it's a unique style there's a
lot of attention to detail in the show
if you look at a tree none of the trees
are exactly the same they have different
lines because everything is hand-drawn I
think the hardest feature that we've had
to develop so far has been combat the
combat stuff is definitely the most like
intense technical gameplay part of it we
knew we wanted to keep turn-based had
made a critical mistake he pissed you up
because that works really well for
timing and comedy and allows us like the
conceit of the boys playing a game
within a game but we definitely wanted
it to be version 2.0
I think we can all agree that this kid
shows a lot of potential we're expanding
upon the combat moving from more
traditional JRPG turn style to something
that's a little more tactically based
and that pretty much allows our players
have a lot more flexibility in terms of
how they attack combat stay out of the
street damn kids
you go to the large deck being able to
pick which heroes they want at their
sides combining powers and abilities and
positioning their characters adeptly
you're actually having to think a little
bit more about your next move and you
know maybe even two three moves ahead
yeah you want to be complex enough to be
fun and challenging and have strategies
but you also want it to be simple enough
that it looks like South Park and it is
just still fun
we establish Institute that you have a
magical butthole and so this kind of
goes to the next level work like you get
and we make your farts more powerful
than what it was and stick a treat there
like could start to bend time yeah if
you make us really rips it rips all in
the space just a really rip or they can
yeah you can really rip one which again
it was one of those things like oh
that's a great idea but then when you
start to put it into a video game system
you know it's it's really hard to figure
out so I think we figured out a good
yeah I think we figured out a good time
fork system a game is such a different
animal than a TV show or a movie or
anything I don't want to just a movie
where I press X a lot what I'm psyched
about what fracture is that I just like
the fact that there's like something
that we are doing that we couldn't do in
a show and there's a way to experience
the town and jokes in a way that you
couldn't do in the show now I'm going to
be those moments where you're gonna look
and go oh my god that was really cool
we're really excited we're excited to
tell this particular story
saspa the fracture backhoe it was
originally called the butthole of time
yeah you know they ran it past the
whatever and they said you can't put
button to retailers won't put bug
retailers want to put it there on a
shelf so I just sat there in my desk for
hours and I'm like a pothole butthole
my whole butt hole by hole available
December 6th get the stick of truth free
with purchase pre-order now for Towelie
bonus content